Peter McDonald author of zap on the
cover of your book it says the victory
in Vietnam why did you think a book of
this type at this point was them was
going to be read well I suppose the I
better started why I wrote the book
around the thirtieth anniversary of the
fall of D and being Phu they had put a
picture in the in a newspaper of this
man that sitting at Dien Bien Phu he was
a bit of a hillock wearing a uniform
smile at the camera and it struck me how
strange it was that he was a man who had
made such an enormous impact on the West
and nobody knew anything about it and
that it would be a great thing to be
able to write a book about it so that
was the seed that was sown in 1984 I
wrote the Vietnamese embassy in London
and said that I would like to go to
Vietnam to meet him and to write a book
about him it then got pretty
bureaucratic they had to refer to Hanoi
and so on the man I was dealing with was
posted back to Hanoi the new chapter
know much about it the whole thing faded
away and I got involved with another
book and I didn't really do anything
about it for quite a long time but then
in 1988 I began to think about it again
and in 1989 I approached the Vietnamese
embassy again it was a long delay
nothing much happened I given it up
really and then this letter came saying
it was a appropriate to go to Hanoi in
December of that year because it was the
45th anniversary of the founding of the
People's Army and that I could go and
write about zap and about the People's
Army so that's really how it started
and then of course there was the
business of researching writings on so
to answer your question directly I mean
there was no feeling in my mind that
that was the right time to produce the
book it was events that picked me up and
took me along and therefore there was no
particular timing and thing I did hope
though that the events would have faded
a bit from people's minds because of the
trauma that had been experienced both in
France and in in America and I think
that maybe the book wouldn't have gone
at all early on
soon after those events and I find now
with passage of time that in fact in
France they still feel tremendously
uptight about the Indochina war and
perhaps and perhaps a bit surprisingly a
little less so in the United States is
general Zapp still alive yes oh yes when
did you last see him I saw him in
January of 1990 how much time did you
spend with him I spent several hours
with him spread over a number of
interviews what was he like
I really didn't know what to expect in
the sense that I had only seen the
picture of him I had read that he was
not very well physically and also I had
read that you know he was suffering from
Parkinson's disease Hodgkin's disease
and wholeness solving and he was kind oh
man
so I really didn't know what to expect
and as a physical presence the
interviews were conducted in what used
to be the prime minister's residence in
Hanoi and I ride there in good time and
waited for him to appear he rolled up in
a big black staff car a Russian Zil I
think they call
with a uniformed driver and an aide and
he came up the steps with energy and
pumped my hand and was full of beans
full of Bon Ami
so I there was no problem of getting our
reporters who like he wasn't standing
off or being arrogant in any way so it
made things rentable easy to conduct the
interviews what language did he speak
we spoke like we had a woman interpreter
and she was translating English into
Vietnamese and back who is he who is he
who is he well it's a remarkable story
if I can slightly digress here I think
in in the modern world we live in as a
great tendency to make people either
black or white or positive or negative
and you know very little shading in
between and therefore for decades the
Vietnamese have been regarded as
communist baddies if you like and the
people at the top end of it have been
regarded as as the causes of all
problems that arose over the year
personally I feel of course that people
are not all good and not all bad and
that the mix of things so to get back to
your point who is he I think he was a
man of exceptional intelligence who
showed it at an early age who did well
in his school in sense got promoted to a
better school and was bright and highly
intelligent throughout all the time that
he was growing up perhaps a bit too
bright in the sense that he was highly
nationalistic and anti-colonial and to
the French and that was his chief
motivation in the beginning
he was born in 1911 so we're talking
about the 30s at the time when he was
developing if you like I think that like
a lot of people in those times in not
only in the Far East but all all over
the world in America in this country
there are people who looked at communism
as a means of perhaps sorting out some
of the world's problems and I'm troubled
I think of course time has shown that
that was entirely wrong
the system is proved to be unworkable
but people in those days didn't know
that and I think he he switched to
communism he read the writings of Ho Chi
Minh it appealed to him and I think he
switched in his allegiance to communist
nationalism if you like he asked you do
before you go any further can you make
the statement and they can't remember if
you made this specifically in the book
that he is the most successful living
general in the world yes I would think
that that is possibly true it's very
hard to think of any other general I
will certainly living today perhaps he's
the most successful general the 20th
century and what did he do to become the
most successful well I'd like to go back
to to pick up the thread a little bit
more about his development because he
got highly involved in this communist
theory he was expelled from school for
subversive activities anti-french
anti-nationalist activity would he live
he was at school in Hanoi but he lived
in the central part of pavetta he was
born in the narrow neck
of Vietnam but he began to write for
books and magazines so much so that he
failed to qualify as a lawyer he'd taken
a degreed Hanoi University in law but he
needed a certificate to practice and he
didn't catch this certificate so he
became a teacher having married and
produced a daughter and he was still
working actively in subversive sense
when the Communist Party was was
outlawed in in France and therefore in
the French colony he was told he should
get away from Hanoi he went north into
China he met her Chi Minh and it over a
period of years he worked politically
but at one point in time Ho Chi Minh
told him that he should be the man to
lead the military arm if he lack of the
Vietnamese Communist Party so he then
began to train handfuls of men very
basic peasant type people from the
northern part of Vietnam so to develop
the theme of how he became to be the
perhaps the most successful general of
20th century out of this tiny beginning
which he started off with what he called
an armed propaganda brigade of 34 people
by the time he was finished he was the
commander-in-chief of 800,000 and all
through the development of his military
life he he learned he wasn't taught in a
conventional way he didn't attend a
military school he had read a lot of
military history he was very interested
in the campaigns of Napoleon and so he
and he used to teach also
miniature history so he was somebody who
who knew if you like the basics but he
would not talk formally but he built up
from a ragtag outfit as the months and
years went by from a purely guerrilla
force through to a conventional force by
the time the French Indochina war was
was well into its first phase he had
gone from smallish company sized units
to full battalions to regiments even to
divisions and armed by the chinese
communists he had created an artillery
division to support the infantry
divisions so by the time the French
really got involved it was trying to
quell this subversion they were faced
with not just a bunch of of people
leaping out of the jungle throwing
grenades firing disappearing again they
were faced with a proper well organized
army and this really was the pattern
that he developed he never at any time
had closed spall aircraft for example as
as any modern force would have and
really not until the very end did he
have armor in the sense of tanked but he
had all the other requisites of
conventional warfare and of course his
army grew and grew and had to be trained
so they were properly trained he had
proper training camps and so on and they
were turning out officers and NCOs and
so did let me interrupted before we go
any further to get some background on
you
you're a retired Brigadier what does
that mean to those people who are not
military it's what you might call a
middle piece high rack general a general
yeah
the bottom end of the of the general
rank what year did you retire I retired
in 1978 how long were you in the British
Army
32 years yeah in those 32 years where
did you serve I served in the Middle
East and in Europe and that I didn't
ever go to the fari we're in a war know
now not in the sense of a conventional
war I was though involved with the
British withdrawal from Empire if you
like in the sense that I was involved
with bomb dispersion in Cyprus at the
time when an organization called a-okeh
was fighting against the British to get
us out of Cyprus and I also was involved
in this in the Northern Ireland conflict
which is still ongoing where do you live
now I live in Bristol in the West of
England how many books have you written
nine and what about nothing well I find
a knife that you sometimes unknowing
they come to a fork in the road and and
decide to walk down it I became
interested in the Crusades and when I
was working minister defence instead of
reading the newspaper going up in the
evening paper coming down and hear it
all again on TV I started to read books
about crusade in particularly the
Knights Hospitaller because I was
particularly intrigued by the fact that
here you had the best soldiers of that
time who were actually monks who took
hold of ours were highly disciplined out
of this I researched this for two years
I then spent two years writing this or a
part time and got it published that if
the first book was in fact a historical
novel about the Crusades I then wrote a
sequence of four books the quartet of
books taking one character as an officer
in the British Army parachute regiment
and taking him through the Cyprus
campaign so
intervention Aden Northern Ireland and
the last book was the Falklands
interwoven with them a sort of
flash-forward account of what the third
world war might have been timing wise
that wasn't all that clever because of
course it's it's now history but in a
sense it was valid it still could be
valid in a slightly different way did
the British fight at all in Vietnam
there did the fact that you are British
have anything to do with why generals
that talk to you I think it probably did
I think that a French or an American
author might have been considered to be
perhaps very biased or full of received
ideas put it up whereas a Brit was a
somebody who'd stood apart from these
conflicts and might be that's part has
general zap ever written a book oh yes
he's written several books so I mean
about his you know recounting his
activities no he hasn't I mean he's
written several sort of communist theory
books setting out or regrettably in
rather typically communist jargon
particular lines of sought after the
Gulf War general Schwarzkopf wrote a
book about his activities general Zapp
is not done no do you have any idea why
he hasn't I think it's partly to do with
the fact that in in any communist regime
or they're slightly two-faced about this
they talk about having no personality
cult but of course you had Stalin as
great personality you had a jiménez
great personality
almost deified but having said that I
mean the theory is that you they rule
they govern in committee and therefore
yes a man may be a high-ranking person
within the committee but in theory he's
got no more power than anybody else and
the decisions are taken by the group
so I think they have no tradition if you
like of writing a personal account and
certainly perhaps it wouldn't be very
acceptable for him to do so
when Ho Chi Minh died they sanctified
him built this mausoleum created a focal
point if you like for for the regime and
men who were with him particularly as
time passed they grilled a sort of faded
away I don't think they want another you
know a leader in in that sense did you
go see Ho Chi Minh in the mausoleum yes
what was your reaction to it I went to
Hanoi with my younger son we went in a
cyclo up to the ho chi minh museum we
had to get a pass to get in at the hand
in your camera we then were taken by a
soldier to the head of the queue because
there was a great long queue of
Vietnamese waiting to pay their respects
so we went into the mausoleum pink
marble walked up these long shallow
stairs and then you turn sharp right
right again you're into this room which
is guarded by uniformed soldiers with
fixed bayonets standing in the corner
and then the queue of people just
shuffles slowly past does a right angle
another right angle Ho Chi Minh's lying
there looking very yellow in a sort of
yellow light in a glass box they have a
slightly lower pathway for the little
kids to walk around so they're not sort
of training around a doctor and you know
the whole thing was macabre very strange
how long were you in Hanoi about two and
a half weeks only did you see others
besides generals that I so a lot of
people yes yeah they were very good in
that sense they wheeled in a lot of
people
so does veterans who had fought both in
the end of China war and in the in the
American Vietnam War and they seemed to
be free to speak their mind and talk
very freely inand I taped a lot of
interviews and some of them I used in
the book I think that they brought a
sort of flavour to it which was
interesting in that it showed perhaps
for the first time their point of view
about what was going were you ever
concerned that they were setting you up
and just giving you people that would
say exactly what they wanted them to say
um this was a possibility of course I
mean I use new touched earlier on on was
the fact that I was British instrumental
in getting me there I think the fact I
was an established author was also
partly and the fact that I had been a
soldier was part it probably he felt
easier talking to somebody who'd been a
settler than two journalists but I had
to declare the fact that been in the
British Army I couldn't you know just
present I was a person who had no
military background so I think from
their point of view they must have been
a bit suspicious of me you know I just I
want to come here and and do this
similarly I mean I was slightly
suspicious and we've just suggested in
it
maybe they weren't feeding me the right
stuff but I did get the impression you
know from long life of dealing with
people that there wasn't dissimulation
going on that these I mean occasionally
they trotted out the party line but then
they've been living with the party line
with brainwashed and you know
automatically but a lot of the time
these people not quite old man were
humorous and and direct and I didn't
feel that they were setting it up
how many Americans did you talk to well
actually out there none of crime in
preparation for you've been in
preparation
I spent one of my postings was in a NATO
headquarters which had a lot of American
officers in and over the years I had
always been interested and I spoke to
them a lot and then of course the the
key figure was general Westmoreland whom
I interviewed when he came to England
and what did you learn from him anything
new well I think what I learnt really
and it wasn't and if you like directly
from him but he underlined what I had
begun to to feel and that was that the
war was fought from American point of
view for the right motivation in the
sense of they felt that there was a
tremendous threat of communism creeping
through the world they felt they had to
do something about it but having taken
that basic decision I felt that they get
they got in deeper and deeper as time
went on and kept digging a bit deeper
and deeper now from the military point
of view
the great mistake was that the way to
win the war was simply to pile on the
hot iron if you like more so there's
more bombs more aircraft and I did this
despite the fact that clearly it wasn't
working so I think one of the big
military lesson if you like was you have
to take a deep breath and and say well
this is not the way you know going to do
something else and military action is a
form of somebody very famous once said
putting politics into a fort
so therefore if your military action is
not achieving the political aim you have
to stand back
the other big mistake politically and
whom I to say but I mean this is my
feeling was that personalities began to
drive the whole engine
in other words lyndon b johnson personal
involvement became a matter of pride and
he could not back down and therefore the
american people were taken along on the
basis of political pride and the wish to
stand again and get reelected again and
so on again he didn't stand back and say
is this the right thing to do when did
this book first hit the bookstores in
the united states and in january this
year any sense of whether or not selling
it's slightly disappointing from my
point of view because a great many
servicemen were in vietnam and you know
we're talking millions and therefore one
would hope that there will be several
tens of thousand books so but it hasn't
gone like that I hope it may do yet did
general Westmoreland have any say about
general Zapp yes he liked him he knowing
he didn't know he admired him
he felt not surprisingly that that this
man must be amazingly successful general
if to achieve what he did he did say
that tap was very profligate with lives
and I think that this is a criticism
that's been said very often that jab had
no concept of sanctity of human life
used to throw so it was in and let them
get churned up and so on I think this is
a matter of perception
first of all it was not long after the
Korean War in which the Chinese had used
the human wave tactics that they were
short on equipment and technology
therefore mass attacks and the whole
concept of submerging the enemy with
human beings was something which was if
you like except in in the east so to a
certain extent and [ __ ] had Chinese
military advisors perhaps the the human
wave tactics if you like was something
that he accepted to begin with there is
another factor to which is because of
this lack of of of technology men with a
rifle had had to balance things off the
French compared through the Viet Minh
you know were extremely well armed they
had an hour air arm to support the
ground forces when the Americans got
involved of course they were even you
know ten times more equipment oriented
and technology oriented than the
Frenchmen so in a sense the only thing
jab could do was to use manpower since
he could didn't have the technology so
what I'm saying is there was a sort of
balance here yes he he had to accept
casualty but this was a way of balancing
of the adverse technology how tall is he
I would say he's about five three five
out of three and what kind of a life
does he live now you in his residence no
I didn't go
I would say that obviously as a man who
until very recently there was a member
of the politburo he lives a comfortable
life is he revered in Vietnam I would
say so yes yeah near the end of the book
he talked a lot about general
Westmoreland you have a chapter called
disintegration room and he has some
statistics in it I want to read you say
when American servicemen finally quit
Vietnam they left behind them 71
swimming pools 160 craft shops 90
service clubs 159 basketball courts 30
tennis courts 55 softball fields 85
volleyball fields two bowling alleys 357
libraries and there were post exchange
shops full of jewelry perfumes lingerie
booze as someone put it was like a walk
down Fifth Avenue why did you put that
into that brain he was making the point
that um it was war the American Way it
really reflect back to what I said a bit
earlier on I mean general westmoreland
point of view was that if he made life
that much as possible like life in the
United States the morale of the soldiers
would be high my point is that if you
expect soldiers to go into the jungle
and live in appalling conditions of heat
and mosquitoes and water and torrential
downpours and so on and live a really
hard life is it actually worse for them
in my view to come back to be chopped it
out at five o'clock in the evening when
they've done their firefight and come
back to an air-conditioned canteen full
of steaks and you know a nice coca-cola
that's truly my own reaction that they
didn't actually use the large numbers of
soldiers who were there to the best
possible degree because
a lot of them were involved in producing
all these amenities and considering that
sodas only did a year anyway I think the
right mental attitude should have been
okay guys you're out here for one year
you're going to have one hell of a time
but this is how we're going to do it and
fight the war not two there are other
statistics there which which are quite
compelling the number of troops actually
deployed in frontline at any given time
searching out the the Vietcong or the
North Vietnamese army was tiny
proportional to that's why I put it in
there because I think it rather
graphically spelt out another aspect of
of this attitude of the way to fight the
war he asked you about this line and
there was another rule for when they
were in battle you're speaking about the
North Vietnamese do not mistreat
prisoners something that generally
speaking they tried to abide by now when
our American POWs who are back in
country now hear that what do you think
their reaction will be to that I hate my
guts probably but again it's it's a
matter of perception if you these people
must have seen how the Vietnamese live I
mean the Vietnamese basically a peasant
society living on on absolute basic
subsistence now for a soldier who has
come from a very affluent nation but
they're talking about the French or the
Americans or anybody out there taken
prisoner by these people he is going to
be suddenly expected to live it as a in
a way which he had no conception of and
I think that's why I say it's a matter
of perception I think that of course
there were times and they were harsh of
course people had terrible privations
but I don't think was laid on especially
I think that the ordinary prisoner in
the Central Prison in Hanoi for
no worse off than the ordinary American
GI who has a misfortune demeanor from
what you saw in your and you been to
Hanoi before by the way there are limits
first time I've been what did you see
there what were the conditions of the
people living there well I was really
quite amazed because one of the problems
in Vietnam of course is a huge
population float at the time and we're
talking about you know in the 70s you
talk about a population about 36 million
it's almost doubled now for both the
north mister yeah and so one the first
impression was at Hanoi incredibly
overcrowd the second was that it didn't
seem to have had a lick of paint or
Warner and any real furbish meant and
for forty year it was rather like when I
crossed over into East Germany when the
wall came down and you know you put the
clock back fifty year and exactly the
same in Hanoi but I mean there were
beggars around and so on there were
people obviously living it at a very low
level but generally the people
themselves were in a better shape than
than the city do you give any other
chapter called the trail do you give
general Zap credit for the Ho Chi Minh
Trail essentially yes I think so
I mean came back to what I said earlier
on the business of committee decisions
and so on but in the sense that he was
the driving force throughout you know
the the pivotal person yes I think so
it was a remarkable achievement and done
with very little to begin with anyway
than just human power I can't find it
but I'm sure you remember you you talked
to a
soldier who fought the war who told you
about a special I mean that they use
this on the trail when they cook their
meals so you couldn't see small is that
as invention that so for instance
Americans didn't know about how did it
work
how about so basically what they did was
to when they created an oven which had a
bit of a tunnel dug behind it and the
smoke was blocked off at the front and
was pushed back if you like through this
tunnel with cheddar a small vent most of
the smoke carbon particles were absorbed
into the earth and therefore they could
cook and create hot meals without
telltale gushing zuv smoke grants a sky
you say us statistics show that in 1968
the year the greatest trail usage by the
way how where did the trail start how
far did it go into the south it started
off in North Vietnam and came down
through last into Cambodia and it
started off as I explained in in the
beginning with just a small group of
people trailblazing if you like the next
development was to have larger groups of
people man packing stuff then gradually
they created a harder trail and they
used bicycles they didn't ride the
bicycles they were heavy-duty things
which they adapted but could carry quite
a considerable weight of stuff slung
over the crossbar so it then became a
trail of hundreds of ant-like people
pushing these bikes down this trail and
that grew became a metal road and
eventually they were running great
convoys of stuff I think they ended up
with three laterals about seven off of
takes into the various parts of Vietnam
let me just read this at your statistics
show that in 1968 the year of greatest
trail usage women estimated 150,000
Vietnam
he's traversed the route 171,000 tonnes
of bombs were dropped more than one ton
for every infiltrator how many of those
are they hit well very few very few why
well
I remember talking to an American airman
who had spent two tours in Vietnam I'm
saying f-111s up and down the trail and
he would explain to me how he would take
off and fly cab rank if you like up and
down just inside the the border in
Vietnam and of course the the this
amazing technology which the Americans
had developed enable them to put sensors
down so sensors along the trail which
relayed information which was then
computerized collated and sent back to
their craft actually flying so that when
they're up there going up and down
flying cab rank taking a suck every now
and again off one of these big tanker
aircraft flying above them to keep
themselves up in the air they would
suddenly get instructions to zap at a
particular target and they would go
ahead and do that but then you have to
remember the conditions that you're
actually trying to hit a narrow trail
surrounded by jungle and so on they did
hit the trail often they hit people but
a lot of tonnage was was scattered
around on either side of it if they
hadn't had the trail were there one more
that's a difficult one I think I also in
the book I say that they needed a
relatively very small amount of tonnage
here was 60 ton a day to keep the the
Viet Cong and the infiltrated North
Vietnamese army going I think the answer
to your question is that without that
trail they wouldn't have got that six
sounds and they couldn't have got it in
by
any other means so probably no other
wouldn't but although you know there the
American air effort was enormous in the
fact that it killed or rather that it
destroyed a large number of vehicles in
the latter days of the Ho Chi Minh Trail
came back to this American friend of
mine who I said to him what were you
successful he said Peter we we killed
off ten thousand trucks I said that's a
hell of a lot of trucks he said no
better that's nothing there were a
hundred thousand truck tell her that me
summed it up in a way and that was a
sort of proportion of success of all the
books you've written where would you put
this in your satisfaction level um oh
pretty high I mean in many ways by
Father give me a tremendous amount of
interest and satisfaction but fiction
writing in other ways is a different
thing had general Zapp talked to any
body else since the war in the same vein
not you not that I'm aware of no I've
never seen any evidence I mean he
obviously has spoken to to exodus'
strange enough I had a in response to
that book I had a letter from a man
called Allison who was one of the people
in the deer team which is mentioned
right at the beginning the American
group went into North Vietnam to help
their regime in he saw the book and
wrote and he in his letter he said that
he had actually met that but and and
obviously he does meet people from time
to time but I don't think that facility
had been offered of not only his
interviews with him but the sort of the
backup if you like him
from the military side I went to their
staff colleague in fact she spent
Christmas Day which will always be a
memorable Christmas day as far as I'm
concerned sitting in this rather
broken-down barracks on the outskirts of
Hanoi talking to a bunch of yet made
general eating bananas and drinking
green tea what do they think about I
mean had are they boastful about the
victory no I won't say that
no I didn't strike me I mean why did
they think they won both the NBN food
and home French Indochina war and the
amount of thing they felt I had the
moral ascendancy you point out several
times in your book that public opinion
played a very significant role in their
country and in our country tell them
what's what was the difference well I
think that innocent I suppose I've
already thought about this but I think
the crucial difference was the public
opinion to them was a positive factor
and in America it was a negative factor
and that maybe it was the real crucial
thing in the whole episode what I mean
by that is that basically there are
simple peasant people they were brought
up in a Confucian ethic of obedience
obedience to older people just slightly
digress here when I was leaving Hanoi
they had little
celebration lunch to which I was invited
with my son and they produce some nice
food and some beer and so on actually
they asked me to buy the beer but that's
all but I stood up at there I was asked
to say something at the end of it and I
stood up and said I'm the oldest man
sitting here and it had an electric
effect they have this if you like this
reverence for older people
I say I'm digressing but it was exactly
the right thing to say that you can
heard a pin drop they were not
listening to some foreigner they're
listening to an old man now going back
to my theory because they have this
Confucian idea of of of respect for
order and and obedience generally it was
much easier to persuade these simple
people that they were fighting a
righteous cause I think the impression I
have is that that there was very little
doubting in their mind that they were
doing the right thing that the French
were interlopers and so the Americans
had to get them out now on the contrary
side you have the media you have a
highly sophisticated population much
more difficult to convince and perhaps
without that underlying moral tone which
which this still exists in in in some of
these other plays was general Zapp a
communist first or a nationalist first I
really I think only he could tell you
that I think that the impression is
certainly that it was a development what
would be very interesting of course
would be to be able to to talk really
talk and get a true answer as to what he
feels about communism now and in that it
has ceased to be tenable as a as a
political theory and that everywhere
except in turn in Vietnam to some degree
but although that the barriers are
coming down and they're beginning to get
capitalist and out of North the North
Korea is about the most stringent
communist country left in the world
that's the only one and you I mean even
Cuba now is is is not what it was in
that same so that you seem to UM he must
surely understand that that a lot of
what he put his faith in there was a
shimmer a few like it was the fantasy
again the year that you interviewed him
was
1990 were there any questions he
wouldn't answer yes but I don't think in
the sense that you mean yeah you know
that he shied away because of some
political overtone that could have been
difficult to judge that particularly you
know you're not talking directly in the
same language and it's all coming
through an interpreter bit difficult I
mean I think that she shied away at when
he was talking about the air defense of
Hanoi and I said to him he said we we
had a way of beating the the the bombers
when I said what was that and he said I
don't want to talk about it you know it
was he was in full spate about something
else
in fact what he was talking about was
that they would send off one of these
surface-to-air missiles which would then
attract all the electronic gadgetry
flying in the American air formations
and they would followed up on the same
beam if you like a few second days were
the second one and the fact was it was a
substitute it drew away the fire and all
the electronic missiles and so on and
the second one would hit the target but
that's what he was talking about I
didn't want to answer it because it was
a bit of detail didn't want to get
involved did the North Vietnamese or the
Vietnamese now did they record your
interview with him
no I recorded part of it my son
we borrowed or hired a video camera from
them and my son recorded part of it but
it wasn't officially recorded now and
out of the interviews that you did what
would you say were the most important
things you learned and did any of it
surprise you
I don't know if you're talking about the
[ __ ] interviews particularly are you yeah
um no I mean I did get the feeling that
um he was repeating a lot of what he had
thought for a long time
if you see what I mean it was difficult
to to break into his his train of
thought did he give long answers yes it
tend to be very verbose and of course
this makes life difficult in it when
it's being translated anyway because of
poor interpreters is going crazy trying
to keep up and and so on so there were
difficulties in this um I think I can't
sort of think of any particular thing
that struck me being very surprising but
some of the interviews with some of the
veterans were quite surprising I mean
like for example one of them says I said
to him did you have malaria and he
looked at me astonished and said yes of
course everybody had but I have 100% we
had malaria I said what did you do about
it is there nothing you know I mean know
that now this again is part of that
attitude isn't it if she see what I mean
the the relatively soft West in contrast
to this hard basic peasant eastern
attitude I said but you must have been
very ill oh you will you have to lie
down for three days and you got up and
got on well that I think that was
surprising to me you know not much time
a lot to cover just I want to get if I
can sir um brief questions and maybe
some brief answers so we can write and
see what's in the book yeah case on what
role the Battle of Khe Sanh what role
would that play in the war it played a
bigger role of course in the American
consciousness and it did in the
Vietnamese in a sense it was another day
and being Phu and from lyndon b johnson
downwards everybody was keyed up to the
fact that there must not be another day
and being food what does that mean for
people never heard of
in right well then be enthuse the coup
de Graaff you like of the Indochina war
yet managed to lay siege to a French
fortress which had been built astride
the road into Laos he managed to produce
55,000 sodas plus a large number of guns
and all the ammunition that was needed
for these gun and surround this place
and it was one of the classic battles of
history
he eventually ground them down and
eliminated the French garrison at Dien
Bien Phu which consisted mostly of
paratroopers and Legionnaires a cream of
the French army for the French it was a
traumatic defeat what year shattering
1954 that it for the French Danielle I
mean it just happened that the day he
took some of May 1954 the conference
opened in Geneva to discuss amongst
other things the future of Indochina the
French had the ground cut away from them
they had no way they could go back they
just pulled out I hate to jump around
but there's a lot of I'll come back to
run your son you keep mentioning how old
is he and what does he do
he's a portrait painter he's 33 years
old and how much did he had to do with
helping you on the book oh not at all
it's that well tremendous moral support
she's a great chap full of humor
vietnamese loved all laughing all the
times on he was a tremendous from that
point of view he took notes for me but
natural writing though did you go
anywhere else in vietnam no no I didn't
have you sent a copy of this book to
general zap yes I have any reaction
though we talked before where the
cameras came on about the name Giat what
is the correct way to pronounce it and
how do you pronounce it and how
Americans pronounce oh I always used to
say vana gooey and gear but they say
Vaughn winds up so it's like a Z yeah
[ __ ] see ya Oh ten Oh
the Tet Offensive yes what is your view
of that M what impact did the Americans
win the Tet Offensive that night was 68
yes militarily yes yes they did I mean
there's no question about it and general
Westmoreland is absolutely clear that
the casualties inflicted on on the
Vietcong we're enormous and there's no
doubt of this one Vietnamese general
Tran branch our who says who wrote later
that they were completely decorated
that's the wrong word it means to kill
off one-tenth there were much more than
a tenth that went that they never really
recovered from that until [ __ ] was in a
position to launch a full-fledged
military assault
so military yes no question about it
psychologically it was almost a death
knell what what do you think general
zaps real talent is I I would say energy
he must have been a man of enormous
determination energy and their
strategies he was a strategist he was an
all-round very clever military man I
mean logistic V as I've just touched on
this business day and being through the
problems of shifting these tonnage ease
with guys pushing bicycles and man
packing stuff but absolutely gigantic to
actually inspire people to do this must
have been a tremendous achievement you
contrasted the first of all you said
that general Westmoreland and general
Zapp read the same military strategist
Klaus woods and others hmm yes how do
you know that do you ask him both yes it
did either did that have any impact on
him I mean in what sense I mean in other
words they're both generals they both
studied the same military strategist in
history yes they obviously came out of
looking at it a little differently
all right yes are very surprised to hear
general Westmoreland tell me that he had
not
the end of China war because he never
did apparently not I liked him
admired him and you know I don't want to
say anything he just hurtful to him but
it did surprise me that he had not
studied this because after all he was
fighting the same people in the same
general and they had fought the French
for nine years so I asked him actually
if they had studied it at Fort
Leavenworth or at the War College and
they happen and so I think perhaps that
was mistake in European which American
President got us in deep in Vietnam or
at Lyndon Johnson my thing
I mean Kennedy started with Eisenhower
on the domino theory Kennedy picked up
that baton and ran with it
lyndon b johnson was was committed
already when he got there but as i've
said write a beginning perhaps standoff
and a bit of thought and taking advice
of people this year long for a long time
it was thought that the Vietnamese were
acting on behalf of a sort of proxy for
the Chinese history teaches you that the
Vietnamese load the Chinese always have
done for a thousand years it's very
unlikely that they were going to spill
that blood in order to hand the whole
thing it would come at a time
after looking at the Vietnam War what in
your opinion are the lessons the it was
a tragedy in every sense for everybody
involved for the Vietnamese for the
French for the Americans appalling waste
of life and the money and resources that
were sunk in the whole thing I think
that the lessons are that it is very
easy to whip up sentiment the media for
want of something to say will pick up a
ball and run with it
and the people because this is human
nature you sit there and you watch the
screen and you believe what you read and
what you're looking at and what you read
in the paper in both cases you the
French and the Americans you had this
tremendous surge of or feeling that you
had a great enemy here that had to be
killed up I believe that it was you know
the Dominos theory has been shown not to
be correct that the Crumlin Asia has not
fallen to the Communists I was in in
Kuala Lumpur a month ago a thriving
modern country one city in a in a modern
country the nothing communists about
that that totally capitalist and loved
it and yet that was part of the theory
that we were fighting to prevent Burma
Malaya and all those falling trees
here's what the book looks like our
guest has been Peter McDonald and this
is the victor in Vietnam
the book is zapped the general who
headed up to Vietnam forces both at Dien
Bien Phu and in the American involvement
thank you very much for joining us my
pleasure thank you